i feel like this whole whip gate thing
is is a metaphor dan for all the other
things like they would rather talk about
something that did not happen and and
try to convince people
that the border patrol was whipping
migrants instead of dealing with the
real issue yeah this is the first
whipping incident human history no whip
um and no incident but you almost have
to write you have to marvel at the
democrats ability like they know it's
like that old quote attributed to
sultanates and all the time even though
it wasn't says you know they know
they're lying we know they know they're
lying they know we know they're lying
and yet they still lie it's like
everybody knows you made this story up
okay we have the photos we have the
photographer and they're still doing it
but why are they doing it that's what
matters
because we have a department of homeland
security secretary now you ever see that
meme on the internet you had one job you
know like the post office guy throws the
those in the garbage it's like dude you
had one job the guy's title is homeland
security secretary and yet they ask him
on the weekend show with chris wallace
how many people are in the united states
and he's like it reminds me of that old
uh you know pete puma thing from woody
woodpecker how many lumps you want i
don't know three or four he's like how
many people are in the country because i
don't know 10 000 12 000 could be more
like that's a big error right it's like
imagine like dana's doing the show with
bill and like what time do you get out i
don't know you get out at nine but maybe
nine ten maybe
like your only job my man your only job
is to know who's in the homeland you're
the secretary of homeland security and
that's why the whip story's important
because they have totally failed on the
border it's been a catastrophe they're
lying to america and it was a convenient
distraction and sadly a bunch of useful
idiots ran with it jessica one of the
things about the secretary is that when
the whip thing first was came up he
defended the border patrol agents okay
overnight like maybe from a phone call
or something maybe like like like the
bat signal went out like actually no
we're going to trash the border patrol
agents falsely
and by the next day he said they're very
troubled and that this shouldn't happen
by the end of the week he said it was a
sign of systemic racism and something
that didn't happen
well and before the investigation it
concluded to me that was just the
easiest way out of this we're looking
into it if you don't want to say they
were reigns versus whips and you don't
let me just interrupt but one of the
problems with that is that the president
of the united states
chief he said there will be consequences
and they will pay
correct it was i mean there was clearly
a lack of communication across the
branches there with that and i
understand and we talked about this on
friday and i got panned on twitter for
not being as familiar with uh rain
culture as i should be you grew up in
tribeca we understand i taught her
everything
absolutely but i'm learning so much
every day here um
but
if there had been communication across
departments with that i think that
secretary marcus's response on day one
was the correct response which is we're
going to look into this the first time
he spoke
as the leader of the people that are
being attacked for no reason right i i
want to press back a little bit on what
dan was saying about that they're just
using this as a distraction i think that
we know that everybody uses an optics
scenario when they can to be able to not
talk about a thing that maybe you have
to but chris wallace pushed him and he
did have to talk about it and that's how
we got the ten to twelve thousand
haitians that have already gotten in
here we learned a lot about the coveted
protocols we know that people are being
sent back who are testing coveted
positive um but the this idea of
language being such a sticking point
it's something that i never understand
you know chris wallace says there's a
flood of migrants says it wasn't a flood
who cares you have 30 000 people under a
bridge you can call it whatever you want
it's too many people who are desperate
that's like crisis remember when they
wouldn't say it was a crisis for so long
katie the other thing that's interesting
like well we might i'll be thinking this
or maybe not all but
we're thinking this does not look good
the
criticism of the biden administration
from the left
is also quite strong and i think we all
have to think about that right their uh
concerns are that um
these migrants never should have been
sent back that this was the wrong thing
to do they don't offer other solutions
and they complain that the republicans
don't offer any solutions congress
hasn't done anything about it and i and
i get all that but i don't think we can
lose sight of the criticism of biden
coming from the left as well well on the
left is is driving border policy for the
democratic party i mean it's very clear
in my orcas this weekend when he's asked
about well what are you doing to prevent
this from happening in the future
knowing that we have thousands more
people who are in south america coming
up now because they know the door is
open and that thousands of people are
being released into the country and he
doesn't give any solution and if you go
back to the campaign trail joe biden
said in august of 2019 we can absorb two
million people a year in this country so
when we're looking for solutions when
you look at democrats and they were
asked if they would give free health
care to illegal immigrants they are
perfectly fine with this so when the
question of is this going to continue
what is the solution they don't want any
solutions to this problem and in terms
of the whip gate hoax it wasn't just a
miscommunication between branches about
them changing their language this is
very clearly a strategy to scapegoat and
accuse border patrol agents doing their
job to distract away from the fact that
there were thousands of people
under the bridge and the big question is
well who suffers here americans suffer
border towns suffer why is there two
sets of rules for american citizens so
if you trespass you get prosecuted for
that but if you trespass into the
country one final point there's been
this talking point from people like uh
congressman waters that these are just
people seeking asylum from haiti they've
had it rough well the facts are that
they they were space they went for
asylum in south america and have been
living in south america for years
after claiming asylum they are coming
here because the door is open which is
and when you claim asylum falsely that's
also a crime that democrats don't want
yeah the root causes weren't a problem
in chile
listen as far as i remember there's some
there's some nuance of this people are
talking about so we're not sending
anyone back to haiti right now because
of everything going on in haiti so
that's i mean democrats are pointing
that out as well and so the thing that
chris wallace pushed him on that i
thought was the best thing he got out of
him was sir why did you ever let them
across the border to begin with when you
go back and say oh boy in 2019 this and
in 2018 that the difference was the
remain in mexico policy because
something that border patrol will tell
you people on horses and texans will
tell you is those migrants don't have
any more right to be in mexico than they
do here so once they are here we can't
just push them back across the border
and that's why it was so important for
border patrol officers to have the tools
they need to stop people from getting
across that river and under that bridge
to begin with trying to take advantage
of our system our own reporters are
showing their paperwork that shows that
they've been wherever they've been and
shows their residency in south american
countries they're ripping them up and
throwing them away before they get to
the border they say oh i'm a haitian
migrant and you can't send me back to
haiti because it's a mess right now and
so they're taking advantage of our full
system the democrats have worked really
hard to give them that opportunity to do
and it's nothing against those people
but it's everything to do with the
people in this country and the people
that i know in dalton georgia that came
here from south american countries some
of them illegal and then their kids
became daca and some of them are
naturalized
in the fact that once you get here and
you live in the shadows in this system
you never are a part of the american
dream
and that's what's important develop an
immigration system that lets people
become a part of the american dream
otherwise it's just a class system and
you're wanting as democrats to invite
people into a worse scenario almost
because now you're living in the shadows
three or four families to a home sending
most of your money back to mexico for
mexican migrants it's a mess and they
know it i don't think that anyone who is
here quote unquote living in the shadows
and and we know these people living in
cities like new york and dc my father
works in oregon um in farming there are
a lot of people out there who are there
illegally none of them would trade their
reality living in the shadows to going
back to where they came from we give
people they would much rather be a part
of what we have going on we can't
necessarily grant citizenship to
everybody and we're giving
opportunity to people to take jobs that
americans will not do how do you know
that maybe you should offer new i think
it's not okay and then not to worry
maybe if we didn't have somebody but
you're you're mounting an argument for
the illegality of immigration right now
because it might be morally superior and
that's not how this country works well
they
should go through a legal process if
they can that's why the vast majority of
them pay taxes also into phantom
accounts just if one day they do get
caught they can say i've been paying
into your system i respect american laws
as best that i can yes maybe i got in
here the wrong way but i want to that's
not the way the law works it's not as
best as you can it's like it's the law
it's just you don't get to respect it
like when you feel i don't like
obamacare but unfortunately i don't get
to say the same thing well that's not
true i would say that we are off to an
amazing start for a monday hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else